that's right sarah jane 37 pages we've
been waiting almost six months for it
and here it is sue gray's report it
takes
us all the way across the events uh from
may 2020 at the height of the pandemic
through the easing and then the second
lockdown all the way through to april
2021 it gives us a narrative about what
happened and the conclusions and really
sue greg comes up with three big things
the first is all about the culture of
drunkenness at the heart of downing
street and the top of whitehall
during the pandemic let's start in june
of 2020. now this is the leaving due for
somebody at the cabinet office now this
event was attended by the then cabinet
secretary by senior civil servant mark
sedwell his deputy and the head of
ethics he brought a karaoke machine sue
gray said the event lasted for a number
of hours there was excessive alcohol
consumption by some individuals one
individual was sick there was a minor
altercation between two other
individuals so a fight in the heart of
government during a pandemic is
extraordinary and she then takes us
through events all the way through
christmas where there were secret santas
and
more drunkenness and the the behavior
really seems to get worse so let's fast
forward now to april 16th 2021 and let's
hear sugray's account of what happened
at that event which is a leaving do for
james slack who was the director of
communications those president were
asked to leave the building of number 10
by a number 10 custodian or security
guard a number of those president drank
excessively she says and then a number
of individuals gathered near a child's
swing now that child's not any old child
that is boris johnson's son wilf his
child swing and slide in the garden and
damaged it by leaning on it and playing
with it this was noticed the next
morning and reported to number 10 stuff
so you can see how over time it wasn't
the behavior got better it actually got
worse now the second
big conclusion that sue grace allows us
to draw through the course of the 37
page report is that they knew what they
were doing look at this this is another
director of communications arguing with
the most senior official in number 10
about the bring your own booze party he
says well i won't applaud the gesture
but a 200 person invitation for drinks
in the garden of number 10 is somewhat
of a comms risk a pr risk in other words
in the current environment and lee kane
goes on to say that he won martian
reynolds in person and said did dominic
cummings sue grey couldn't find the
records at that but you could see that
um there were warnings and then when
martin reynolds the most senior uh
official in number 10 at the time uh uh
was wrapping up the event and messaging
a special advisor in number 10
about a story uh that the media had he
said oh that's a completely done story
but better than them focusing on our
drinks which we seem to have got away
with got away with was the view of the
people in number 10 at the time and sue
gray helps us understand that
but then the other thing that this
report does is it goes into exactly what
the position of boris johnson was
through it and he she doesn't link him
to the decisions of the senior uh
officials in number 10 so that'll please
i think those in danny street quite a
lot and critically what she doesn't do
is investigate what was thought by many
to be the most toxic event of all which
was a fl um a party in the flat of
number 10 in november 2020. now this was
the point at which lee kane and that
infamous advisor dominic cummings left
government and there was a faction
number 10 delighted that he'd gone sue
gray began investigating this earlier
this year and she starts to write about
it in her report she said well the event
began in the flat at six o'clock and
five special advisers attended and the
prime minister joined them at eight
o'clock and there was food and there was
alcohol and the discussion carried on
late into the evening so was it a party
well that's where the detail stops
because she then goes on to say i
stopped investigating when the police
took over the police decided that they
weren't going to investigate or issue
any fines and here we have it following
the metropolitan police announcement on
the 19th of may i considered whether or
not to conduct any further
investigations this event but concluded
it was not appropriate or proportionate
to do so in other words the potentially
most damaging event of all wasn't
ultimately investigated by su grey
because the police decided no fines were
necessary so what does sue grey conclude
well again another reason why there
might be some cheer in number 10. it
sounds as if she's going to be quite
damning the senior leadership at the
center both political and official must
bear responsibility for the culture that
she sets out across all those 11 months
but then she goes on to say that in
january she made some suggestions and i
am pleased at the progress that's being
made in address addressing the issues i
raised in other words she is saying that
yes it was bad but the changes have been
put in um course she is happy with so
she doesn't seem to be suggesting any
further action is necessary and upon
that judgment i suspect sarah jane you
will get many tory mps saying that is
enough for us to say boris johnson
should stay